the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we make a transition now to the final
meant of our course in which we and and
and this transition always induces a
kind of guilt in me a kind of deep
ambivalence and disappointment and
awareness of the simplifications and
reductions that are embedded in all
syllabi and in all curricula and this is
a good opportunity for me to remind you
that even the primary emphasis of our
course which is on certain forms of
American film is itself highly selective
and simplified and reductive as you as I
told you they weren't in the Hollywood
system they were making 500 films a year
think of the small number we've actually
seen right it's the tiniest sampling of
what's actually available and what I've
tried to do is give you a kind of taste
of what that phenomenon of the the
Hollywood film was like without trying
to pretend at all that I was coming
anything close did not not just couldn't
be exhaustive we couldn't even be
extensive or were or mildly serious
about about trying to do justice to the
complexity of that body of material and
that's even truer of course in this
moment in this final in these final
moments of the course where I try to do
sort of a brief acknowledgement of the
fact that there are profound and
powerful traditions of cinema outside
the United States in fact some more
profound or at least as profound and
some more powerful and many people would
say then then the achievement of
American cinema than the achievements of
American cinema and perhaps the
strongest example of that the most
dramatic example of that is French film
it has a kind of parallel history and
virtually every stage of the history of
French fit of American film you can find
a kind of counterpart story in French
film as if it's almost as it and in fact
there have been historians who have
tried to argue about the priority who
invented film were the French more
advanced than the Americans who first
developed forms of serial movies who
first developed forms of the of the
chase of the comic chase film in the
early silent era and so forth and and I
think these arguments are not very
helpful about
priority but it is very important to
remind you that the history of other
national cinemas and most especially the
histories of the history of French
cinema has the same complexity nuance
detail that American that American film
has we can speak man and just let me
very quickly remind you I've asked I
asked you to read a chapter from David
cooks history of narrative film that
deals with the complex achievements of
French film in both the silent and in
the sound era and I hope you read those
chapters and reread those chapters
closely and think about them just as a
reminder however we you know there are
arguments just as just as innocent and
and the earliest films that were made in
the United States are associated with
the Edison Company so the same kind of
thing is true for the Lumiere films that
were developed in the 1890s in France
and of course just as they were
pioneering directors who explored and of
the nature of cinema the possibilities
of this new of this new medium in the
United States an identical activity was
taking place in France and some of you
of course know about the central
contribution of the early pioneering
director may a who cook talks
extensively about him in the chapter I
asked you to read the man who were in
effect invented the science fiction
movie in the film a trip to the moon and
did so many other early experiments with
for wit with combining the reality of
film with certain forms of surrealist
imagination the tradition of discourse
about film in France probably is deeper
and law has a longer life than in any
other Society
and many people would say that along
with Eisenstein the great Russian
director it's the French who elaborated
the first systematic forms of film
theory and there were in the in the set
in the in the Sun in the silent era and
in the 20s in France a series of
developments that encouraged a
systematic kind of theoretical approach
to film I won't mention names here or
particular or particular
theorists simply acknowledging the fact
that that the French tradition of
discussion about film and in the
creation of film is at least as rich as
that of any other society I say this
because making Jean Renoir stand for
this whole rich tradition is unfair even
to so remarkable and influential
director as Jean Renoir but having made
that basic apology let me now make my
transition to Renoir himself some of you
will recognize a Renoir name I hope he's
the second son of the great
impressionist painter Auguste Renoir and
in fact you can he was himself a a
subject of his father's paintings
there's the there there's the young
Renoir with blond reddish hair as he
appears in one of his father's paintings
in the period 1895 to 1899 when the when
young Jean appeared in a series of
paintings in some of the pay in some of
the paintings his his gender is very
ambiguous he looks in not just that he
has long hair but even seems dressed in
a in a kind of girly way and he
sometimes mistaken for a girl when
people look at the at the images but
isn't it interesting that this great
film artist is himself in a series of or
izl is already in a series of him
immortal works of art created created by
his father Jean Renoir grew up in a in
an atmosphere of avant-garde almost
avantgarde frenzy in many of the most
distinguished artists and performers of
the day were regulars in his household
because his father by the he was born
late in his very late in his father's
life and his father was already a very
famous painter by the time Jean was born
when he grew to adulthood he around the
time of the first world war he served
first in the cavalry in 1913 very
briefly and was actually injured he was
kicked by an animal I think a horse or a
mule kicked him and he was laid up then
he re-enlisted in the infantry where he
was wounded
and he said finally this is very rare in
the First World War he ended up serving
also in the Air Force and he was briefly
a pilot in the French Air Force so he
served in all three branches of the
French a First World War and the film
you're going to see tonight the great
masterpiece such as the great
influential of deeply influential film
grand illusion is a war film of a
certain Renoir a sort as you'll see this
evening he he also served briefly in as
a prisoner of war during the First World
War and and that experience of course in
some degree in some central way informs
the story and the experience of grand
illusion which is also a story about a
film about prisoners of war during
wartime you can get some sense of do we
have some pictures of others of his
father's paintings let me just these are
just of course among some of Renoir
repairs most famous paintings and I
thought that it would be you would be
interested to see them to get some sense
of the to remind you of the importance
of his father's art and of the asking
you might also as a way of encouraging
you to imagine what the impact might
have been on the young on the young boys
who have grown up in an environment in
an environment like this I don't know
that that does look like John but maybe
it is another picture of John yeah he
had kind of that jolly face and that may
be among the oldest images of him that
had him at the oldest age that his
father painted him oh he worked on his
first day after he emerged from the
First World War he he had conflicting
ambitions but he moved into into film
fairly soon he wrote a script in 1924 he
began to make his own movies around the
same time I have a very brief list of
some of his films would you put those up
I want to talk very quickly about a
couple of his films and then turn to
certain other important matters well but
the most important thing to say about
memoirs Jean Renoir's career is that
like some important American directors
his career spans both the silent and the
sound era and he made some significant
experimental silent films of which the
most well-known in terms of experiment
is the film the little MatchGirl based
on a Hans Christian Andersen story and
it uses certain kinds of surreal imagery
that's very surprising especially you
know in a silent film and and I
mentioned the that he made a silent
version of a novel by Zola nananana as a
way of simply also reminding you from a
very early stage Renoir understood that
the movies were were a form that could
sustain the most ambitious kind of
artistic act it aims and and
it's a measure of his sense of that that
he would adapt even during the silent
era a film by one of France by one by a
classic French author but his mostly but
his really significant work begins in
the sound era and in what's often called
his French period and the films I've
listed between 31 and 39 not a complete
list of his films this is a very
selected list but it's a list of his
much of some of his most significant all
of his most among his most significant
films for sure known really important
title is missing although there are many
other interesting films that he made and
it's the period between 31 and 39 we
left France after rules of the game
while when the second world war was
imminent
came to the United States and the films
of the 40's that I've listed there were
made in Hollywood and he was very
welcomed in Hollywood and there are
people who film scholars who are great
fans of these three films these three
titles that he made in the United States
then he left the United States at the
the film the river which many Renoir
buffs loved as much as his primary films
although I find it a much slower and
less powerful film although
incredibly beautiful it's it in India
and the river is the Ganges and it's a
very very remarkable meditation on the
power of place in in society but his
central achievement are the films of his
French period running through the 1930s
and I want to say a word about some of
these one of them last year stars the
same character who stars in boodles
saved from drowning you're going to see
a clip from that film in a moment
Michelle Simone and Ian announced a kind
of bug complexity and ambitiousness in
in memoirs work that that would deeply
significant it it had a kind of moral or
political claim it was a film set in the
in the slums and it was about a an
aborted or an abortive or tragic love
affair between a working a working man
played by a proletarian played by
Michelle Simone and a prostitute who is
unkind to him at the end and and and and
throws him over at the end and the the
film's into the film's interest in the
life of the low in the lives and
circumstances of the lower social orders
was a was was especially significant
significant and Michelle Simone's
immensely powerful physical performance
was also memorable and you'll see a
version of that in a moment
in in the following year he made what
many people call his first great
masterpiece of film called boudu saved
from drowning it said the French title
is voodoo Sauve desu saved from the
waters days oh that the waters plural
and the French title is a little better
as I'll try to say at a moment he made I
mentioned the Madame Bovary partly again
to show you something about his ambition
he's trying to say in effect look the
film is an equivalent art form to the
great novels of our past in 1935 he made
a film that many identify as a
forerunner of of Italian Neel
the movement will be studying next week
and I talked a bit about Tony in next
week's lecture it's a film very
experimental in certain ways it uses a
lot of non-professional actors and and
again it's about the circumstances of
the working class in some way it's about
it's about French quarry worker workers
who are treated with a kind of with a
kind of with a kind of clarity and and
attentiveness that that previous films
had had not had had rarely granted to
members of the not only the lower social
orders but here immigrants not even not
even natives his two masterpieces come
in 37 and 39 again remember I've left
out a number of titles is a selected
list the film you'll see tonight grand
illusion and what many people think of
as his greatest film a deep complex
satire on contemporary french life in
the previous before the war cool rules
of the game the primary label that's
attached to John Renoir's work is that
of poetic realism and it's a yeah it's a
way of trying to distinguish a form of
moviemaking that emerges of which when
war is the most dramatic and powerful
exemplar but there were many other
examples in in in in in French cinema
and and it's worth talking a little bit
about Atty forerunner to the tradition
of poetic realism a director named Jean
Vigo who died tragically young as you
can see from his dates who made the
three films of the three titles I've
listed there and these these films had
an immense influence on later filmmakers
a zero for conduct is a is a film set in
a it has surreal elements in its its its
its plot it's hard to follow but it
essentially it tells the story of
children going back to school it's a
it's a it's a and following them once
they get into a kind of boarding school
and rebel against their house masters
and they there's a sort of comic element
in the film and there's also an element
that might be called an impulse toward
lyric retardation by which I mean that
the retarding is the retarding of the
plot I don't mean mental retardation
right there's a kind of lyric impulse to
celebrate what's going on right in front
of you at the expense of the plot as if
as if as if the story almost stops
moving at a certain point while the
camera and the stand the and and the
camera itself sort of indulges in in a
in in witnessing a spectacle so
intrinsically interesting in itself that
it seems to lose interest in the ongoing
story so there's this tension in Vigo's
films from the very beginning in what
some scholars have seen a tension
between denotation and connotation
between the denotation being the simple
realism the ongoing story right and the
connotation being the poetic or lyrical
impulse of the film to sort of celebrate
life in its complexity in its nuance
without any interference from the demand
that you follow a story and this tension
because there's a fundamental element
not only in poetic realism but as you'll
see in the Italian form of this called
neo realism that emerges out of it and
is somewhat of a grittier and more
historically politically engaged kind of
kind of drama IVA kind of kind of film
even though it's a direct outgrowth of
the kind of thing we're saying about
poetic realism and in both forms in both
kinds of film there is this retarding
impulse this lyric impulse in which in
which the story's desire to get on with
itself is sometimes in conflict with the
camera's desire to look at what it sees
to to to to to revel in what it in what
it wants to look at and so so you only
go partly in the because of his tragic
life short life and and partly because
I'm he was the son of an anarchist of a
political anarchist of a serious Atticus
to who who wrote about theories of an
era of anarchy anarchism as a political
movement and he himself was very hostile
to Authority Jean Vigo and his films
animate a kind of the anarchic anti
established anti-establishment Arianism
that is the
that is a very distinctive he's almost
always on the side of the of the weak
and the powerless um let me say a few
words about the key what we might call
the key features of neo-realism one of
the most fundamental elements of
neo-realism is what could be called a
meson sense style that is to say it's
committed to long takes the poetic
realism is interested in the external
world and in the relation between
characters and the outer world and and
and although it will use abrupt cuts of
various kinds it won't do so at the
expense of your experience of the outer
world it wants the audience to take in
what it sees and to make judgments about
it it doesn't try to in the in the way
that certain of other kinds of styles
might do to manipulate your response and
quite the in in so dramatic away and
what follows from this means on sense
style is what some scholars have called
in camera editing because what's going
on and because the camera the tape look
because the camera is whether style is
committed to long takes what will happen
is the camera will alter its focal
length its depth of field or it will
simply move and change its its it the
the the object of its gaze while it is
in operation so then it's instead of a
series of cuts that are made in the
editing room in its the cameraman
working the camera
who's making certain decisions that in
another kind of film would be made by a
film editor after the fact and this
creates an effect of not exactly
improvisation but an effect of an effect
that creates the impression that there's
a kind of sometimes at its most powerful
more compelling moments as if the camera
is actually almost a living witness to
what it's seeing and it's and responding
in very nuanced and sometimes very
abrupt ways to what it sees and hears so
there's sometimes moments in in both
poetic realist films and in Italian
neo-realist films in which a noise will
occur and you'll suddenly see the camera
turn to find out what the noise is as if
it as if the camera is humanized in this
kind of sight and what follows from that
if the camera is all not always but
usually set in eye level it does not
give
a lot of fantastic distorting angles of
vision because it's not interested in
that kind of surreal or expressionist
representation so reason sense style in
camera editing a second fundamental
feature would be filming on location
right no more in studio is there's a
kind of there's a kind of gross
fundamental realism to these kinds of
films because they because they use
natural lighting they in the Indians
they insist or try to insist on them on
themselves as as actually photographing
a world you recognize as real not a
world that has been artificially
constructed in a studio in a studio
space
what follows also from the location
filming is a commitment to what might be
called true light and sound right it's
very rare in these kinds of films to
have external sound the sound even the
music that comes up in many of these in
most of these films this is a wonderful
habit of Renoir himself sometimes you
actually think the music is not a part
of the drama but then you discover it is
almost all the music in Renoir's films
is is part of the dramatic texture it's
not imposed from the outside it's not
it's not a soundtrack that doesn't grow
out of the action so if you hear music
in a Renoir film I'll show you an
example of it in a moment from voodoo it
turns out that the music is being played
by characters in the film and you
actually end up seeing them with their
instruments so true light and sound and
and and that what that also means is
sometimes sound is obscured sometimes
sound is is is overlapped with other
noises sometimes dialogue is hard to
hear because there are noises in the
real world we that this was an aspect of
a number of American directors in the in
the post studio era and especially in a
film like McCabe where Altman does this
kind of thing and I think I think that
it it's it's it's very probable even
though I don't know this for certain
that all when him self went to school on
these films and knew the experiments
with sound or the treatment of sound
that was characteristic of Renoir
memoirs films and other forms of attack
of both French and and Italian forms of
of real as
what was called realism so and then and
then two other features one already
implied in what I was saying a camera
that's very fluid in what emotion not in
gigantic motion but very subtle kinds of
motions and if you watch rent warrants
camera you'll see that it's almost
constantly making these minor
adjustments to what it's looking at her
to what it were to or to what it wants
to see and then and then finally
something I've already said there's a
great emphasis on what could we call
depth of field that is to say you are
aware of the dimensionality of the
images you're looking at so there's a
background of middle ground and a
foreground and very often you will see
the camera change its focal length and
what will if the foreground was in in in
focus yes you'll actually experience the
camera shifting its its focus and
bringing in the background that had been
out-of-focus before and the effect of
this while it because it takes place
within your experience of viewing it
doesn't take place behind behind edits
is to make you part of the process in
some sense again to make you feel that
the cameras behavior is a it is a part
of your experience of the film that
you're experiencing the film through a
medium that has a kind of immense
sensitivity to what it's looking at and
immense respect for what it's looking at
well so key features let me just
summarize them again amazon send style
which means in camera editing especially
filming on location commitment to to
light and sound a fluid moving camera
commitment to depth of field what we
might call again creating this tension
between a kind of lyrical impulse a kind
of a kind of celebratory or a poetic
impulse as some people have said and and
an impossibly to to denote the world to
capture the world to describe which to
dramatize the world fully well I think I
can show you or or dramatize these
principles more fully for you from if I
give you some examples but as as a way
of introducing this I want to talk very
quickly about one
formulation immensely influential
formulation about Renoir that I think
you'll find helpful and interesting and
these are lines that have been written
about Renoir by the great critic Andre
bezu who was a great champion of
Renoir's work also a great champion of
Italian Neorealism and one of the great
theorists of of them of the cinema and
we can capture I think when I think that
bizarre captured something of Renoir's
importance in these passages from his
book titled Jean Renoir published in
1971
no one has grasped the true nature of
the screen better than Renoir so wrote
better no one has more successfully read
it of the equivocal of equivocal
analogies with painting and the theater
plastically the screen is most often
made to conform to the limits of the
canvas and dramatically it's modeled on
the stage you see what do you what Beth
is saying is he's reminding us that when
a new technology emerges old habits are
so deeply embedded that it's very hard
to free oneself from them even though
there's nothing inherent in the new
technology that requires you to see the
world in the ways that the older systems
did and there is a period of transition
that's involved with the period of
experiment and discovery what bizarre is
saying here is that Renoir is one of the
great pioneering discoverers right
because with these two traditional
references in mind directors have
conceived their images as boxed within a
rectangle as do the painter and the
stage director and in fact it still
happens today with lazy or foolish
directors right when more on the other
hand understands that the screen is not
a simple rectangle but rather the
surface of the viewfinder of his camera
it is the opposite of a frame right this
stuff that goes on outside the frame if
it's right and this is a brilliant piece
of writing I think technically this
conception of the screen assumes what I
bizarre shall call lateral depth of
field lateral depth of field that is -
but it's an oxymoron again where a
contradiction but how could there be a
lateral what he means is
you become aware of things going on on
the margins of the of the visual of the
visual field even outside of what you
can actually see since what we are shown
is only significant in terms of what is
hidden from us and since the value of
what we see is therefore continually
threatened the meson sin right what is
put in the scene right the meson sin
cannot limit itself to what is presented
on the screen the rest of the scene
while effectively hidden should not
cease to exist the action is not bounded
by the screen but merely passes through
it and a person who enters the cameras
field of vision is coming from other
areas of the action and not from some
limbo or some from imaginary backstage
you get this think how exciting this is
what a what a fundamental insight it is
into the way a film can become
compelling and why it is that so many
films might seem factitious to us
despite the gross reality of the
cinematic image likewise the camera
should be able to spin suddenly Renoir
is full of moments in which the camera
will make wide swaths sometimes
sometimes 360 degree circle sometimes
180 degree turns in order to remind us
of what has not been in the frame of
what is on the margins of the frame so
the camera should be able to spin
suddenly without picking up any holes or
dead spots in the action well I want to
give you two examples of this which are
among other things instances of what I
call put my outline back up instance of
instances of what I call visual style as
moral vision and I'll hopefully be
explaining that term as we as we look at
it so so the first clip I want to show
you is from the film you're going to see
tonight and it's a way of alerting you
to qualities not just in this scene but
elsewhere in the film that I hope you'll
become much more attentive to because
we're taking the time to single them out
now so here is a scene from are we ready
from from
grand illusion from relatively early in
this in the film now as I've told you
this the film is about prisoner French
prisoners of war so here's a scene the
French put there these are prisoners but
it's the First World War
they are allowed to receive packages
from their from from from in the mail
and what by and what people in what
people their relatives and friends send
them is fooled very often oh right
alright can you make it a little louder
not that it really matter what can you
freeze it one second look at look at the
window there why is that significant
what do you notice in the window already
movement right you know you see how and
the way that scene began we know where
that character has come from even though
these two characters are in
confrontation and talking to each other
we're aware of activity in the window
behind them were aware of other people
in the room it actually may seem as if
it's very easy to create this effect but
of course it's profoundly difficult and
and Renoir is the pioneer in creating
these these kinds of effects how fluid
the camera is how that's what I want you
to watch for your awareness of effect of
action that's going on partly outside
the frame alright continue
the man at the head table is the
wealthiest of the prisoners and he gets
the best food so he shares it with his
comrades it's a tremendously good meal
for prisoners this is the least violent
war movie ever made the characters is
individuated in this scene I don't have
time to talk about this watch it - man
maybe I'll say a bit about it tonight
when I introduce you first but each one
of them we can almost we can tell what
social class they belong to from their
dress from their mode of speech you see
how quietly but complexly the camera
examines the space and that's younger
man one of the great well the central
characters and one of the great French
actors all right we have to stop this
because I'm sorry I have to cut this
short it's a brilliant scene watch for
it tonight comes fairly early in the
film watch how each of the characters is
individuated as this scene goes on how
crowded the scene is in one sense how
how you're aware of activities and even
conversations that are taking place
outside the frame of the of the of the
camera itself and when the camera shifts
over to one set of characters you're
aware of other conversations that that
are ongoing there was the sense of
reality that this style creates is
profound
and compelling it seems to me powerful
well but I want to show you another and
even more dramatic clip because partly
because it comes from a film you've not
seen because and because it captures
certain other qualities in in Renoir
rent in rewards work and this is this is
the famous ending of boudu saved from
drowning let me set the scene for you
while Christians getting it up in this
scene this comes at the very end of the
film it's a the film is a satire and
will do is a bum a cold shower of whom
there were tens of there were thousands
if not tens of thousands living in Paris
during the era when the film was made a
kind of [ __ ] like like like the
character that the Chaplin figure plays
in the American films although Michelle
Seymour is a much more massive figure
than Chaplin and in the very beginning
of the film he plays this he seems to
try he jumps into the river to try to
commit suicide because he's lost his
beloved dog he's a figure of despair and
a middle-class bookseller named les ting
Gua spying him through his spy glasses
he's looking out of the out of his book
out of the windows of his book of his
bookshop sees this bum at first he'll
all what a perfect bomb he thinks to
himself what a perfect embodiment of
what a [ __ ] is and then he becomes
upset when he sees the guy jump into the
river he runs out he dives into the
river to save him and it turns into a
kind of comic scene of saving people
gather on the bridge and look down and
so forth he pulls him out brings him
into his home his wife is very resentful
of it but eventually she adapts and he
moved into the middle-class booksellers
home and of course he wreaks havoc there
because he stands for nature itself
he can't be civilized or tamed right
he's Buddhist so saved from the waters
right so he saved from the waters at the
end but as you'll see at the at the
beginning but as you'll see at the end
of the film he's back to the waters so
here so what happens essentially is
among other things in the course of the
story this this figure of raw nature
turns out that he can't quite be
civilized one of the things he does is
he manages to have a love
fare or to or to seduce I couldn't
shouldn't call it a love affair both
less ting was mistress our young maid
who works in this house and his wife and
a kind of semi scandal occurs in which
far in which the in which the [ __ ]
character paid played by Michelle Simone
wins the lottery and becomes very rich
so he then very marriage of convenience
is arranged and he's going to marry the
maid that had been the booksellers
mistress and this sort of straightens
everything out because there had been a
kind of scandal brewing and in the fan
and the final scene of the film is the
wedding party in which in which in which
boo do his new bride The Bookseller and
his wife are in a boat together
celebrating the wedding and of course
these images would have invoked Renoir
pears films of a paintings very
powerfully as well many of John Renoir
is treatment of films of set in nature
are said to have been influenced in some
ways by his father's paintings there's
Michelle Simone and his new bride you
see how there's music but it's coming
from source inside the story
that's the bookseller in the back with
the white hat everything looks wonderful
hey I'm one thing I think one reason I
wanted you to see this is look how
leisurely this is where is it going
we're at the end of the movie yet now
and it will tell how the film sort of
almost as if it doesn't even at this
stage doesn't want to end doesn't want
to move forward all right he reaches for
the flower
now remember that he's just been married
what's happening to her where's he going
you know often when I showed this to my
classes because I'm always worried about
time I get impatient here but in fact
it's a bad reaction because the film
wants us to savor what it's doing it can
you feel that sort of lyrical tendency
just to sort of look at the world in its
beauty as if the impulse to tell a story
and the impulse to photograph the world
are in some degree in conflict of course
the world keeps resisting the categories
you put it in the camera keeps
discovering new things to look at so
here boudu comes ashore
think of how anarchic this vision of
life is because he's just deserted his
new bride and his new wedding and all
that right doesn't seem to matter he
gets up on shore he's still wearing his
wedding clothes and this becomes then a
highly symbolic moment he sees a
scarecrow now he's going to shed his
middle-class identity by changing
clothes with it
I suppose one fundamental aspect of the
satire is he's what the film is saying
is look nature is always more untamed
and difficult than middle-class
romantics imagine right it's not a
tameable thing oh here he comes
eating his bread newly free again
identifies with the goat shares his food
with the goat
pay attention to the camera
okay shut it off at one point in his
book on basavanna's book on Renoir he
talks about this sequence and I want to
remind you that he talks about this
sequence in an era before it was
possible to easily reproduce right it
was an era of long before video tape
long before television actually and when
you wanted to watch a movie again you
had to get projectors and show them so
very often when Bassam was writing about
his film he was working from memory and
he makes some technical mistakes but he
gets the essence of the scene right
listen to this he says Renoir there
moralist is also the most realistic of
filmmakers sacrificing reality as little
as possible to the thrust of his message
the last scenes from Buddha could serve
as an epigraph to all of Renoir's French
work will do newly weds throws himself
into the water not exactly it's an
accident it's important that it's an
accident it's not like he was planning
his escape right because he's nature he
doesn't he doesn't think he stands for
the natural but but by accident the book
the boat overturns and voodoo makes his
his escape because it's possible to do
so it's not as if it's premeditated
that's important and dramatic or
psychological logic would demand that
such an act have a precise meaning is it
despair or suicide no it's not at all in
fact it's just an accident
voodoo is and we'll do it without maybe
even fully realizing it is trying to
flee the chains of a bourgeois marriage
ran more like his character forgets the
act in favor of the fact and the true
object of the scene ceases gradually to
be what we do intends right what is
Buddha up to why is he doing this I
don't even think he's persons right to
even raise the question because what we
think he's doing is just enjoying
himself right then it occurs to him when
he gets on land that he's free of his
marriage right we're and more like his
character forgets the act in favor of
the fact and the true object of the
scene ceases to be Goudas intentions and
becomes the spectacle of his pleasure
and by extension the
join that Renoir derives or we as
viewers derive from the antics of his
hero the water is no longer water but
more specifically the water of the Marne
a tributary of the sin in in August
Michel Simone floats on at tines /
sprays like a seal and as he plays we
begin to perceive the depth quality and
even the tepid warmth of the water when
he comes up on the bank an extraordinary
slow he calls it a 360 degree pan
remember that final move the camera but
it's probably 180 degrees he's
remembering it imperfectly shows us the
countryside he sees before him the world
he sees before but this effect by nature
descriptive which could indicate space
and Liberty regained is of unequal
poetry because what moves us is not the
fact that this countryside is once more
again Buddha's domain although that is
one effect of it Guddu is free and the
camera shows the beauty and freedom of
the world in that in that 180 degree pan
but that the banks of the Marne and all
their richness of detail are
intrinsically beautiful and you're aware
of that aren't you at the end of the pan
the camera picks up a bit of grass or
wearing clothes up when one can see the
dust that the heat and the wind have
lifted from the path one can almost feel
it between one's fingers if I were
deprived of the pleasure of seeing boudu
again for the rest of my days I remember
the first time I read those lines and I
realized what it meant to be a movie
critic or a literary critic think of
what what what's implied by that if I
were deprived of the pleasure of seeing
boudu again for the rest of my life as
if this would be a deprivation too
horrible to contemplate right it made me
realize with my own vocation in a way if
I were deprived of the pleasure of
seeing boudu again for the rest of my
days I would never forget that grass
that dust and their relationship to the
liberty of a [ __ ] the point of this
exercise is to remind you of the immense
power the potency of even a single
camera move think what that 180 degree
pan suggests as Beza
brilliantly
argues for us so the conclusion then is
that the visual style of a film of our
certain films anyway can express a moral
vision and by moral vision I don't mean
moralistic what's more what's what's
didactically right and wrong but a
vision of having to do with the values
and assumptions you make about the
nature of the world there's a moral
vision implicit in the tentative
necessity' n-- see the retarding impulse
of to dwell and linger on things in in
the in Renoir's camera and in the basic
habits of of poetic realism that you
will see brilliantly embodied in the
film you're going to watch tonight grand
illusion
you